hi everyone
welcome to yet another video tutorial on
python programming by simply learn in
our previous video we learnt about list
comprehension in this video we will
understand how does string formatting in
python work
before we get started make sure you
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so what is string formatting in
python formatting a string is something
you will do all the time when you are
coding in python
string formatting also known as string
interpolation is the process of
inserting a custom string or variable in
predefined text
the string formatting methods
format the given string into a more
precise output in python
so it is the process of infusing things
in the string dynamically and presenting
the string now let's look at the
different types of string formatting in
python first one we have is using the
modulo operator so python uses c
formatting style string formatting to
create new formatted strings python does
that with the help of the modulo or the
percentage sign
this is the old way of formatting
strings this approach was more often
used in python 2. so let's head out to a
jupyter notebook and see how this works
so this is my jupyter notebook that i am
going to use for our demo
so let's start with our first example
that is formatting a string using the
modulo operator first i'll create a
variable called name let's see the name
is sean and i have another variable
which has the age of sean let's say 32
now i can create a variable called
string
equal to i'll say
hi then use the modulo operator followed
by s
and i'll give an exclamation mark
give a space i'll say
percentage
name
and then let's
print the string
if i run this we have the output hi
sean so what i did here was
we have defined the variables that we
want to format into the strings
then we have created the string with the
placeholders for the variables so this
is a placeholder
now the percentage s format specified
here tells python to substitute the
value of the
name
so hence we have high sean printed
now let's see another example
this time i'll directly use a print
statement
i'll say
i like
to
then i'll say percentage s or modulo s
chocolate
ice creams
i'll give a full stop
and then using my modulo operator i'll
pass in my value that is eat so here
percentage s will be replaced by the
value eat
now if i run this
you have the message here i like to eat
chocolate ice creams now you can also
add
multiple strings at a time and you can
use variables to insert objects in the
string let's see one more example and
say string equal to say percentage s
is
i'll say
percentage d
years old
then
i'll give a percentage symbol and say
name comma h
and let's
print the string
if i run this
you see here above we had defined the
variables name in age to be sean and 32
so here
percentage s is for name so so on
is
percentage d
is for age so son is 32 years old
so in this example percentage d format
specifier tells python where to
substitute the value for h
and it is represented as a string so
percentage s
is used to inject strings similarly
percentage d is used to inject integers
so here 32 is an integer and you can
also use percentage f for floating point
values and you can also use percentage b
for binary format
all right
now
let's see another example
let's say i have a variable called x
which has
a value dance
i'll say
print
nancy
can
i'll see percentage s and
percentage
s
two
after this
we'll
specify
the parameters let's say x and
sing
if i run this you have the output nancy
can so here percentage s is for x which
means dance so nancy can dance and
percentage s is for the second
parameter which is sing so my result
becomes nancy can dance and sing too
now similarly we can have another
example using
percentage f let's say i'll say print
the
value
of
e
is
now i'll specify my format which is
going to be let's say percentage 5 dot
2 f close the quotation and then i'll
pass in my
value for e let's say
2 4 5 5 3
dot i am just taking random floating
values 7 1 8 2 8 1. now if i run this
you see the result my value for e is
2 4 5 5 3
7
now let me tell you what
5
dot 2f means so here 5
would be the minimum number of digits to
be present in the string these might be
padded with white spaces if the whole
number doesn't have this many digits
and here 2f represents
how many digits are to be displayed
after the decimal point so after the
decimal point we wanted only two digits
so we have rounded it up and the value
is 7 2
all right so coming to the
next type of string formatting in python
we have formatting with the format
string method
so python string dot format method was
introduced in version 2.6 now there are
two ways to do it one is using
positional arguments and the other is
using keyword arguments
so let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll explore a few
examples on this before that let me just
give a
few comments so the first one we saw was
using
modulo operator now the second one is
not an operator this time we are going
to use the
format method cool
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so under format method we'll use empty
placeholder and replace them with a
string value
so
i'll write a print statement
let's say my
message is
welcome to now i'm creating
one placeholder which is empty you can
see here and let's say after that i have
tutorials
i'll give a full stop and then we are
going to use the
format method and inside the format
method we are going to
pass in the value
let's say simply loan
so this
simply learned value will be substituted
in this empty placeholder
let's run it you can see the result we
have
welcome to simply learn python tutorial
so
this empty placeholder was replaced with
a string value that is simply known
cool
now moving to the
next example so we'll be using index or
positional arguments inside the
placeholder
let me create a variable called s1
and i'll type in a message let's say
my message is let's
i'm using my first placeholder and i'm
giving a
position or an index
now in python you must be aware that the
index starts from zero
so i've used curly braces and passed in
zero i'll create another placeholder and
this time i'll put index as one let's
say my message continues like this with
simply loan
and then
we'll use the format method
and we'll pass in the values for these
two
placeholders it should be width
let's see my value for the
zeroth index is
learn
and
my value for the first index is upscale
i'll go ahead and print s1 and you can
see the output let's learn and up skill
with simply learn so here the zeroth and
the first index were replaced by learn
and upscale respectively so this is how
you can use
index or positional arguments inside the
placeholders now you can also
add index numbers into the placeholders
to reorder values now this will affect
the order in which the method replaces
the placeholders let me show you so i'll
create a print statement so let me
create my first empty placeholder and
then i'll continue with my message
let's say called
then i'll have my second placeholder
and i'll continue with my message to
inform that
then i'll have my third placeholder
will be absent
okay
now
let's use the
dot
format method and we'll
have the values for all the three
placeholders let's say my first value is
luke
my second value is
dina and my third value is
john now if i print okay there is some
error here okay
there has to be another
bracket here now if i run it you can see
the message here
so the first placeholder was for luke so
luke called
dinah which is my second value to inform
that
my third placeholders value that john
will be absent
cool now you can
add index numbers into the placeholders
to reorder the values now let me show
you how to do it i'll just
copy this
message and i'll print it here
and here i can now pass in my
index values let's see i'll add 2
0 and one
so here
luke is for zero
dyna is for one and john is for second
index value now if i run it
now you can see the
difference in my message so here first
two comes which means john called
the value at zeroth index which is luke
so john called luke to inform that dinah
will be absent
all right
now let's see one more example this time
we'll be using name or keyword arguments
inside the placeholder
in the earlier examples we saw how to
use positional arguments
or index this time we are going to use
name or keyword arguments inside the
placeholders
so i'll create
another variable called s2
and
i'll have my message let's say v in my
first placeholder i'll have the keyboard
as a then i'll have my keyboard as b
my message will continue
i'll have my third placeholder as c
with
simply loan
and then we'll use the
format
method
and then i'm going to pass in my
keyword arguments
so here we have to assign the value for
a b and c so let's say the value of a is
loan
for b
let's say it is
upskill and for c
let's say the value is grow
now
we need to
print s2
if i run it you see the message here we
have v
learn
upskill and grow with simply loan
let's see we'll replace v with
let's
so the
message is more appropriate
so now you can see let's learn upscale
and grow with simply loan so this is how
you can use
keyword or name arguments inside
placeholders in the format method
cool
now let's look at the
third method we have
formatting with string literals called f
strings so strings in python are usually
enclosed within double quotes or single
quotes to create f strings you only need
to add an f before the opening codes of
our string so this type of formatting is
also called as a formatted string
literal
now when you
use f strings you need to display
variables so for that you need to
specify the names of the variables
inside a set of curly braces and at
runtime all variable names will be
replaced with their respective values
so let's go to our jupyter notebook and
we'll see a few examples
all right
now let me give a comment as
f
strings
okay
so
let's see our first example under
f strings
type
so i'll say
tutorial
equal to python
then i'll have another variable called
subject which has the
value
programming
next we have place equal to
simply loan
and then i'm going to
use a print statement
and then i'll use my
f
keyword for f strings
and i'll see my
message as let's
learn
then using
curly braces i'll pass in my
variable name that i have defined here
first is tutorial then we have
subject from then i'll have the place
let's give a full stop and we'll close
the double quotes and let's run it so
here you can see we have our message
let's learn python programming from
simply learn so here tutorial and
subject
were replaced by python in programming
because we have defined tutorial as
python and subject as programming and
please we have a simply learn and hence
my message is let's learn python
programming from simply loan
so
this is how you can use f strings so
when using f strings to display
variables you only need to specify the
names of the variables inside a set of
curly braces now you can also evaluate
expressions
with python f strings let's see a simple
multiplication
i'll create a variable called n1 which
has a value of 60 let's say n2
has a value of 12
and i'll use my print statement
i'll give my
f
keyword for f strings
i'll say the product of
then i'll create my placeholders n1
and
next placeholder is n2 is
and then using
curly braces i'll do a multiplication
operation
that is n1 multiplied by n2
i'll close my
double quotes let's run it
so you can see here the product of 60
and 12 is
720 let's see i'll make it 10 and
40 if i run it the product is 400
cool
now you can
also use
f strings
in conditional statements so you can use
conditionals in python f strings let's
see an example i'll create a variable
called num which will have a value let's
say 55
then
i'm going to use a print statement
and use my f letter
and then i'll pass in my message is
number even
give a question mark
then using
curly braces i'll have my placeholder as
true if
num
modulo 2 equal to equal to 0
else
display false i close my double quotes
now let's print it
you see here is
number even the output is false because
55 is not even let's say i'll make it 50
and if i run it as number even the value
is true because 50 is divisible by 2 and
hence it is even all right
now coming to the
final type of
stream formatting in python we have
formatting with string template class
now template strings are provided as a
class within the string module of the
python library it is imported as a
module and the
dot substitute method is used to replace
the placeholders
now the format uses placeholder names
formed by the dollar symbol with valid
python identifiers
let's go to our jupyter notebook and
we'll see two examples on this all right
so this is the final section of our demo
let me give my comment as
template
string
okay
so first and foremost we need to import
the template
module so i'll say from string
import
template now let me first run it i'll
create two variables the first variable
is a1 which has a value of
python
the next variable is a2 let's see the
value is
simply loan
then i'll create another variable called
n
which will have my template
function
and inside the function will pass in our
message
let's say
hello
welcome
to
now i'll use my
dollar sign and say let's say
n1
programming
so this is my template that i'm creating
by
again i'll say dollar
and two give a full stop
now i'll say print
and dot
we are going to use the
substitute method so i'll say
substitute
n
1 equal to a 1 so here i am going to
replace n 1 with the value of e1
and then i'll say
replace n2 with a2 all right
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go so here my
output
becomes hello welcome to
now n1 we have replaced with a1 so hello
welcome to
python programming by n2
now n2 we have referred to a2 so
it becomes simply alone so hello welcome
to python programming by simply loan
now let's
see our last demo
again this is on template
strings
so i'll create a variable called stu
name which
essentially stands for student name
let's say the name of the student is
johnson
then i'll create a variable called s
and i'll use the
template
function or the method
i'll say hey
using the dollar sign i'll say
name
how are you
how
are you followed by a question mark i'll
say s dot
substitute
i want to substitute
this dollar name with
sdu underscore name
which has johnson now if i print it
you can see the message here hey johnson
how are you
great
so
that brings us to the end of our demo
session on string formatting in python
so we have a python quiz for you
which string formatting is the best in
python
so please let us know your answers in
the comment section below
and thank you all for watching this
video tutorial on string formatting in
python i hope it was useful and
interesting if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section below thanks again stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here